[Music]
but sabine i've got four more questions
if you don't mind we'll try to keep it
in under five minutes do you mind
answering my fantastic four questions
uh i'll do my best
okay
um so first question i ask is um really
revolves around your life and the
brevity of life the stoic say we should
meditate daily on the fact that we're
all going to die
in the bible uh it is said that the
righteous lived to be 120 years old uh
so we're about you know a third or a
half of the way there in my case maybe a
third of the way there in your case
anyway i want to ask you sabine when you
do depart from this chunk of space dust
what wisdom or values do you most want
to leave in what's known as an ethical
will or in hebrew it's called a zava ah
it's basically something that contains
your personal wisdom for both your
biological children and your ideological
children
[Music]
oh jesus that's a big question um
so
i guess i guess what i'm i'm i'm trying
to communicate a lot is that um we're
all in this together on this planet um
we're not single individuals and we have
to think about how we interact with
other people
on a global scale
and i think i would like to leave behind
a little bit more
awareness about um how difficult it can
be to make sense
of human interaction on such a large
scale like like we see it for example
on social media like i think this is
something that has brought the issue to
a lot of people's attention but it's
also something of course that we we see
in politics right
yes exactly
um
thank you sabine for that answer the
next uh question revolves around a far
more distant future event which is
billions of years from now perhaps if
you've ever seen the movie 2001 a space
odyssey by uh renowned science fiction
author
arthur c clarke
who is the namesake for the institute
here that i um associate director of
arthur c clark center for human
imagination anyway there are these
monoliths and these apes and primates
see them and then they kind of go around
the universe and we're not really sure
what they are but i want to ask you if
you had a time capsule
that would last for a billion years and
you want to put on it or in it you know
not a cd-rom or something but you want
to put something in it that summarized
the grandiosity of humanity of what we
had achieved maybe in science um and you
wanted to do so
what would you put on this monolith what
what would you put in it what fact or
attribute of human accomplishment is
most worthy to brag about to some future
alien civilization
[Music]
so
i i guess i'm afraid i would i would go
for something
obviously high-tech uh
you know wha whatever's available at the
time maybe quantum computer
something like this if i don't have a
quantum computer maybe just a phone
uh just something i chose look that at
least we got that far right
yeah and we made newsletters which you
should subscribe to um
great okay
the last two questions
that's right we tweeted
okay uh second to last question savina
another quote from sir arthur c clarke
who says when a distinguished but
elderly scientist says something is
possible they are most certainly right
when they say something is impossible
they are very probably wrong
i want to ask you sabine what have you
most recently changed your mind about
not that you're elderly but what have
you changed your mind about in science
[Music]
well i i constantly changed my mind back
and forth on a couple of questions one
of them is like it's a modified gravity
or dark matter okay i think i've
switched back and forth a couple of
times
another thing that that we
touched on is the question
um
do gravitons exist
like is gravity actually quantized um or
is it is it emergent
and you really only have gravitational
waves
so so those are a couple of things that
i switch back and back and forth on
um
yeah i i guess that during this whole
pandemic thing
i've also changed my mind on some issues
of science communication uh if that
counts
um i see that that there's a big virtue
in getting things out in a simple form
uh i guess it's not so surprising as a
scientist myself i i uh on this on the
side of
too much information right because i'm
always like they need to know all this
in all the asterisks and the fine print
but uh i i think i realize that there
are situations where this just doesn't
work you know you have to put out a
simple message and just tell people what
to do very good okay sabine and the
final
fourth question of my existential
questions as i called them even before
you wrote this wonderful book
existential physics uh is uh revolving
going back in your own personal world
line
and it
is relevant to sir arthur c clarke's
so-called third law
and he said the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible and guess what that's how i
get the name of my podcast very creative
isn't it i ask you sabina going back in
your life
what mysterious aspect of your life
perplexed you when you're a 20 year old
or a 30 year old and
yet looking back through the lens the
telescope of time
now
would you tell yourself you'd give
yourself advice as a 20 year old to give
you the courage to do what you've done
and go into the impossible
[Music]
well so
i don't i'm afraid i don't really know
how to answer this question i i think if
i looked back uh when i got interested
in physics it was pretty much through
the impossible uh it was it was through
science fiction and you know how
hyperdrives and and and all that kind of
fancy stuff that they have in science
fiction and i wanted to know how much of
it is actually true like you know how
much of it is reassigned how much can
you actually do
um and so yeah i mean maybe maybe for me
that that's that's the thing i i kind of
secretly believe
that it's actually possible to travel
faster than the speed of light um not
within the theories that we currently
have uh but that may not be the end of
the story
maybe the aliens will tell us right
sabine
um well sabine indeed
so if i if they can just actually it's
like this is why i think it matters
because um if there are aliens out there
and they have further developed
technology they would be using the
faster the night drive right
that's right exactly that's the uh the
promise that aliens hold for us if it's
not indeed religion and it is an
existential matter in any case and
sabine i want to thank you uh for
everything you do uh around the world
inspiring literally millions of people
through your videos your books uh your
blog
your newsletter all of which i subscribe
to and and you should too and get this
wonderful new book and her first book
lost in math it's a beautiful uh a
companion to these two uh anything else
you'd like to mention sabina that you're
uh like my viewers and listeners to know
about
no i mean um this is just wonderful love
talking to you i think you you have a
great channel uh with a lot of super
interesting interviews
[Music]
thank you sabine that means the that
means the multiverse to me
[Music]
you